with other countries now steaming past
America what is the number-one thing you
want to see whoever wins the next
election do about this I think there's
gonna be a broad push to making
classrooms more human and when you have
42 people or 30 people even 20 people in
a room and it's all about a lecture even
no matter how good you get that ratio
down it's still a passive experience
you're you know it's what we all went
through here you're looking at a clock
waiting for the period to end and so
what we're talking about is technology
not to replace what's happening in a
classroom but to make the classroom
better lectures can happen at a
student's own pace if a lot of the
problem-solving can happen can we use
the class time for interaction between
the peers interaction between the
between the teacher so even if you have
the unfortunate situation of 42 students
at least let them interact with each
other and let them let them teach each
other let them have more opportunities
to actually interact with the teacher
but it's easy the right move forward for
kids to be doing as much work at home as
they do at school and doing it on
computers which is their natural habitat
anyway no I you know I think actually
one of the big problems and talked a lot
about this is we have this culture of
homework that that creates this illusion
of rigor oh good enough the Estonians
are beating us at factoring polynomials
more homework and all the studies
actually point to well that the single
biggest determinants of student success
are dinner with their parents and
sleeping and homework it's too much of
it directly goes against both of those
things and so and we've been working
with a lot of schools what we're seeing
is if you actually allow more engagement
in the classroom you allow students to
learn at their own pace they actually
learn much much more